g1
e aí
e vai ficar aqui eu tô achando bem mais
fácil esse pau que eu do que o palco ao
vivo lá que a gente está com o coração
aqui nem agora estamos em casa então no
conforto da nossa casa na tranquilidade
da nossa casa tem um tem uma
informalidade assim né tem uma
intimidade que a gente nem se conhece
mas já estamos aqui muito juntos então
que eu venho falar é desde esse lugar da
situação de tá em casa e quando me
apresentei no palco do deck são paulo
falei sobre luto um tema que ninguém
quer falar mas que em algum momento
todos experimentamos né todos vivemos ea
sobre luto também que eu vou falar hoje
mas não esse luto assim do sol o luto de
perder alguém porque esse luto faz parte
desse momento também mas esse luto de
não está nos fazendo aquilo que
estaríamos então ontem eu vi uma frase
no
o que é do olho ver jéssica ele fala
assim o futuro não é mais o que seria
achei isso lindo porque todos nós
tenhamos um futuro aí mais ou menos
desenhado uma viagem que ia fazer um
amigo que encontrar né um evento no
trabalho e tudo isso mudou de um jeito
ou de outro por isso que a gente tá aqui
fazendo como nunca fizemos e como nunca
foi planejado então eu comecei a
perceber nesse 60 dias que estou em casa
que tinha muitos sentimentos aí para
organizar e quero falar um pouco sobre
eles nesses anos trabalhando com esse
tema do luto da empatia eu percebi que a
gente precisa de tempo para conseguir
não só nomear mas para conseguir
entender o que tá acontecendo dentro e o
que tá acontecendo fora então no começo
dessa minha quarentena com duas crianças
pequenas né uma de 8 e uma de 11 anos eu
fui sendo
é bombardeada por tanta sugestões do que
fazer com esse tempo livre então aquela
ideia de agora podemos é fazer jogos que
nunca fizemos o fazer atividades que
nunca experimentamos o como vai ser essa
nossa interação o tempo inteiro juntos
então vamos ser criativos então no
começo eu percebi que tinha coisa que um
deslocamento de eixo porque o nosso eixo
ele se faltava pelos horários e pelas
ações de se ele vir não é o horário da
escola horário de um evento horário de
um trabalho horário de dar uma aula no
meu caso e aí de repente tudo isso caiu
por terra estamos em casa vamos fazer
tudo isso dentro de casa e eu gostaria
de dizer que no meu caso isso não foi
tão difícil eu já trabalho nesse esquema
do home office já tem 11 anos eu moro no
litoral numa casa que é super espaçosa
que tem área verde né que tem quintal
é então que dá para passear dentro de
casa mesmo que dá para gente tomar sol
que tem muito verde então do alto do meu
privilégio eu reconheço que já era uma
facilidade enorme que essa vista linda
que não dá para mostrar para vocês agora
porque ele está escuro que tem brisa né
que tem árvores que tem bananeiras e que
tem um silêncio também mas ali tinha
ainda um desconforto e aí eu me
perguntava por que que eu estou
desconfortável na minha zona de conforto
se a zona de conforto é a mesma por que
que eu tô me sentindo tão inquieta por
quê que estou me sentindo tão mexida né
o que que é que tá acontecendo aqui
dentro então eu percebi que eu tinha
saído desse centro que eu tinha me
deslocado desse meu eixo de ser uma
pessoa tranquila e serena percebi que eu
já não consegui acordar tão cedo dinho
para praticar yoga e percebi nas noites
insones
bom então se você está cuidando aí 3:30
465 horas da manhã tamo junto nela o
bonde da stronda e não tá passando só
aqui tá passando em várias casas e a
gente acorda com aquele monte de
pensamento e a cabeça fervendo e quer
dormir de novo e aí fica aquele ovo é
think então comecei a perceber até mais
irritada mais cheirosa em alguns
momentos sem paciência eu que sempre fui
muito paciente aí
o sendo eu sempre para trabalhar não
tenho concentração vou produzir uma
coisa que levava meia hora tô levando
três horas né leia três vezes a mesma
frase não entendo o que que é isso que
tá acontecendo várias janelas abertas no
meu computador e aqui dentro como se eu
tivesse fechada ea criatividade
bloqueada então se você viver ou está
vivendo esse momento não está sozinha
nós não estamos sozinhos nos momentos
difíceis a gente sempre parece que está
o sente que está mas na verdade não
estamos estamos todos juntos mas
separados é isso que eu sinto e aí eu
fui percebendo que tinha alguma coisa
ali para investigar comecei a perceber
também que meu coração se apertava toda
hora que eu li uma notícia que eu ia
sobre doença que eu ia sobre mortes que
eu lia sobre pessoas passando fome com
os colegas mencionaram aí sobre as
crianças que sempre tiveram dificuldades
sobre as famílias que sempre tiveram
e em situação muito vulnerável então
aquilo ia deixar o meu coração apertado
pequenininho e do outro lado dessa
inquietação uma sensação de estar
sobrecarregada é o que eu chamei do
barnaut ubernaut da quarentena por quê
que horas é que eu vou conseguir fazer
todas essas atividades todos assistir
todas as lives fazer todos os origamis
não teve essa ideia vamos fazer origami
com as crianças gente leva um tempão
fazer origami e como que eu vou fazer
isso e os afazeres domésticos e o meu
trabalho e o tal do homeschooling quem
tem criança pequena tá nessa nessa
tutoria nessa mentoria que é muito
desafiantes que pode ser maravilhosa eu
tô achando incrível experiências mas
tudo isso leva tempo para se adaptar
leva tempo para fazer para acontecer
então comecei a me sentir sobrecarregada
nesse estar em casa com tanto a cuidar
né contanto a fazer ao mesmo tempo me
sentindo um pouco perdida e me
questionando como é que eu vou dar conta
de assis
os filmes tanta séries de lê tantos
livros que eu aposto que no começo a
gente pensou assim não até agora que eu
vou ler aquela coleção ali que tá
naquele instante da literatura clássica
brasileira me esperando não consegui
sair da primeira página porque o que que
tava acontecendo nesse banal então por
que que não tô conseguindo ouvir os
áudio books que eu separei por quê que
eu não tô fazendo uma horta por que que
eu não tô reformando meu guarda-roupa
então a lista de vontades de desejos era
enorme ea possibilidade de realizá-los
não e aí foi aí que eu me dei conta que
todas essas propostas essa dezenas de
propostas que vieram de fora e que
vieram de dentro também que toda essa
vontade de fazer tanto é no sentido de
nos manter ocupados
a mente nos manter vivos e nesse momento
nos manter vivos ativos e saudáveis é um
grande esforço em vários sentidos
inclusive na saúde mental e emocional
que também conta tanto quanto a nossa
saúde física aí começou a me cair uma
ficha como uma boa taurina que demora às
vezes a entender eu fui percebendo que
não era hora de guardar os tapetes que
não era hora de reformar as cortinas que
essas mudanças exigiriam de mim
processos internos e exigiriam que eu
tivesse auto-compaixão comigo mesma alta
empatia comigo mesmo aí fui chegando
perto do tema do luto porque o que mais
ajuda uma pessoa no luto a empatia e o
tempo de elaborar então eu não estava
dando a mim mesma aquilo sobre o qual eu
falo tanto nos meus encontros nas minhas
palestras querendo meu livro então
comecei a me dar conta que eu estava
exigindo de mim uma
o seu desempenho de será super mulher e
a supermãe a super dona de casa ea
superprodução na quarentena como que
então tem que valer a pena esse tempo
quando na verdade esse tempo não foi
propriamente uma escolha né nós fomos
impostos a isso como luto normalmente
eram os impostos ninguém escolhe perder
algo ou perder alguém então aquela
mensagem que o verde e continue
trabalhando continue se divertindo
continue interagindo faça tudo que você
faria fora de casa mas agora na frente
da sua tela e tem a esse grande
maravilhoso o mundo virtual ao seu
dispor e desfrute dele né nessa
segurança do celular uma vida nova
pontinha virtual não fazia tanto sentido
quando aqui dentro e eu não estava
pronta e não era bem o que eu queria
então naquele dia que como disse a
colega agora a pouco foi tão bonito que
ela falou que os dias são todos mais ou
menos iguais então nesse dia que parecia
igualzinho a todos os outros eu me dei
conta e falei gente não cabe tudo isso
simplesmente não
e eu tenho tempo de fato tenho tempo mas
eu não tenho vontade de fazer tantas
coisas virtuais e mesmo que eu tivesse a
minha vontade não tá só à mercê desses
desejos tem essa série de obrigações
para dar conta tem duas crianças aqui
dependendo de mim contando comigo
contando comigo como um eixo nesse
momento e ali comecei a visitar esse
novíssimo sentimento que eu nunca tinha
experimentado do luto coletivo e ali eu
comecei a perceber do alto daquele
trapézio que eu tava segurando aquela
barra sabe aquela sensação tá segurando
naquela barra soltando para ele segurar
uma outra que ali embaixo não tinha uma
rede de segurança ela não estava lá
então aquela rede de apoio que nós temos
antes que inclui a escola os professores
os amigos na casa de um amigo os avós os
parentes né as pessoas que nos apoiam no
dia a dia que estavam todas alguns suas
casas não tem uma rede de proteção uma
rede de apoio né
é por isso que ela é tão difícil segurar
na barra do trapézio me dei conta que
estava segurando na barra olhando lá
para baixo e vem do abismo esse
movimento eufórico eu fólico a
etimologia da palavra eu fora meu fone
que é aquele que o eu está fora então
deste movimento eufórico comecei a me
resgatar visitá-la dentro perceber que
tinha duas intenções nesse super ocupar
nesse super produzir né o primeiro que
era essa de uma ilusão de que nada mudou
e tudo mudou um futuro não é o que seria
e a segunda e talvez essa assim a grande
motora desta conversa é que foi ocupar o
tempo para não sentir
a ocupar o tempo o tempo todo para não
sentir então tão ocupados com o trabalho
com a vida virtual com as reuniões nos
um jitsu no whatsapp no youtube ocupando
tempo em tantas plataformas ao mesmo
tempo estando em tantas lives em tantos
lugares talvez estivesse me
desconectando do sentir então é um
trava-línguas o tempo todo ocupando o
tempo todo para não sentir para não
viver este luto então justamente por não
estarmos agora fazendo aquilo que
havíamos planejado que havíamos sonhado
que estaremos vivendo a um vazio vamos
olhar esse é o meu convite para você
hoje vamos olhar esse espaço que se
abriu esse vazio que se abreu que agora
já se vão 60 dias e dá para enxergar tá
bem liso tá bem mais transparente do que
tava ali no começo é preciso olhar o
nosso vá
nós estamos vivendo um grupo coletivo eu
você todos que estamos assistindo nós
perdemos algo perdemos algo perdemos
talvez não uma vida humana ou talvez sim
uma vida humana próxima mas perdemos a
segurança que sentimos a tranquilidade
né a possibilidade de comemorar o
aniversário de atender um evento de
reunir os amigos perdemos as
oportunidades de luz nutrimos neste
convívio social perdemos a nossa agenda
eu deletei todos os eventos da minha
agenda perdemos a nossa agenda perdemos
o toque mais importante perdemos o
contato convívio beijo abraço perdemos a
chance de nos aglomerar como é gostoso
aglomerar que nos juntar de dançar junto
de usufruir dessa tranquilidade estar em
um mundo que não tinha nada disso e que
está perto era ótimo não era perigoso
não era contagioso
nós temos esse luto para viver claro
vale lembrar como também falaram agora
pouco os ilustres palestrantes que
vivemos no brasil que pessoas nunca
tiveram esse privilégio e eu entendo
isso tem pessoas aqui que no nosso país
nunca tiveram o salário moradia
segurança empregos possibilidade de
sonhar de crescer mas em maior ou menor
escala todos vivemos as nossas pedras
sim deste planejado deste sonhado então
nesta camada reside esse sentimento que
se chama luto esta sua tristeza que não
se sabe o nome essa coisa que te acorda
no meio da noite essa hora que você anda
pela casa esqueceu que você tava indo
fazer essa sensação de abrir o seu
computador já está cansado antes de
começar é o luto o nome disso é luto
esse sentimento tem nome e agora a gente
está fazendo um mosaico de todos esses
eu estou no tecido que vai se formando
como um pedacinho de várias histórias e
que vai ser agregando com todas as vidas
humanas perdidas no mundo todo até esse
momento se a gente sente isso significa
que somos humanos que ainda somos
humanos no sentido de conseguirmos
sentir conseguimos nomear e aí desde
este lugar de reconhecer que sim há algo
errado que sim a uma inquietude ao
cansaço a uma exaustão então agora
podemos finalmente dizer ufa reconheço
minhas pedras me permite senti-la me
permitiu chorar aliás esse é o meu
convite para você hoje se você ainda não
chorou na quarentena a hora é agora tem
uma coisa que eu sou boa nessa vida é
ajudar as pessoas a chorarem o que elas
precisam chorar então bem-vindo
bem-vinda não precisa ser um maratonista
da quarentena não precisa ser o super
produtivo hoje não precisa ser que tá
batendo todas as
e fique à vontade senta e chora quando
acabar esse nosso encontro de hoje de
repente desliga a sua internet é
possível fazer isso não é porque esse é
um botãozinho aí atrás do roteador clica
nele desliga logo tudo ao mesmo tempo a
tv o computador celular e aí você chora
senta e chora se permita sentir as suas
pedras se permita sentir o que foi que
em algum lugar você teve que deixar para
ocupar esse espaço em que momento chegou
o seu vazio e deixa esse sentimento do
vazio de inundar deixa esse sentimento
vir aquele que eles foram que vai
subindo subindo cada um tem jeito né mas
o meu mais ou menos sobe sobe sobe sobe
e deságua e deixa desaguar e chora mesmo
chora de raiva por todo mundo que você
acha tá fazendo tudo errado por todos os
meandros que você discorda por todas as
os profissionais ou não-profissionais
que
10 o disseram que você não queria ouvir
chore por todos que estão acamados por
todos que estão nos hospitais chore por
todos que estão arriscando a própria
vida todos os dias para cuidar de nós
choro de medo chore de conflito chore
dessa ambiguidade que é está protegido
estará ameaçado ao mesmo tempo porque
assim que nos sentimos e o luto é isso
está nos felizes de estarmos vivos e
ameaçados pela eminência da morte que
isso é o sentimento do luto quando a
morte chega tão pertinho da gente que
damos conta que somos assim um grãozinho
obrigado pequenininho perante a
magnitude desse universo chora e a sua
pequenez humana chora de saudades do seu
pai e da sua mãe dos seus avós dos seus
amigos chore eu tô morrendo de saudades
da minha mãe da minha irmã do meu irmão
história de vontade de abraçar de
circular de sair dançando de sentar num
boteco de tomar uma cerveja chora o seu
receio de não ver talvez não
e vão ver nos tão cedo sorry e deixe que
as crianças também chorem pelos amigos
que não estão encontrando pela escola
que não estão frequentando pela saudade
das brincadeiras eles também estão
sentindo eles também estão vivendo o
luto também está nele então se na sua
casa as crianças estão gritando mais ou
brigando mais o nome disso é luto essa é
uma das maneiras de expressar o luto
pela raiva né pela pelo grito ainda bem
que as crianças leitão quem dera a gente
fizesse um pouco mais e aprendesse com
ele também a fazer isso um pouco mais
gritar a nossa raiva colocar para fora e
chora um pouco desse futuro que seria
que não será show é a viagem que você
não vai fazer o namorado que você não
vai encontrar trocas que não aconteceram
a humanidade que hoje enfrenta o maior
desafio da nossa era enquanto a gente
ficasse ocupando de não sentir isso
estamos tapando só com a peneira estamos
enfiando o nosso luto de baixo
e não tem nenhum tapete que dê conta
disso chore desse macrocosmos para esse
microcosmos dessa grande pedra das
milhões de vidas humanas que talvez se
vão para este pequeno universo da sua
casa do que você perdeu e estaria
fazendo nessa noite de sexta-feira caso
não estivéssemos todos aqui então no seu
tempo vamos seu tempo os olhos eu luto
nós temos tempo embora pareça que não
nós temos tempo e aí quando eu senti que
passou respira
e respira fundo percebe que apesar do
luto nós estamos todos vivos que honra
estar vivo que presente é a vida e agora
sim eu te digo que é possível ser triste
e feliz ao mesmo tempo eu descobri isso
na experiência do luto e aí vem o
comprimento do luto que a celebração ao
mesmo tempo que a gente tem tanto para
mim lutar né que tava conversando com a
helena ao mesmo tempo em que todos
perdemos tanto ganhamos tanto o que
vamos celebrar então cadê a tristeza que
eu tiro dessa pilha e de ocupações
internet cassol cibernéticas
e o que que tem lá embaixo quais são os
aprendizados os crescimentos as
novidades o convívio com as pessoas que
amamos aí vem as celebrações cada dia
que eu consigo sair da cama cada dia que
eu consigo fazer uma boa comida que eu
não tenho arroz que eu consigo dar conta
de um milhão de tarefas que não xinguei
ninguém eu consegui fazer um bom papo
virtual consegui encontrar os meus
amigos virtualmente que eu pude
participar dessa live hoje maravilhosa
aqui é o motivo de celebração estamos
aqui graças essa tecnologia é graças a
essa equipe incrível que nos que nos
recebe que nos acolhe aqui com tanta
eficiência apesar das dificuldades todas
que é fazer o que nunca fizemos então
vamos celebrar as refeições o aconchego
a casa a cama quentinha o espaço que nós
temos o travesseiro que nos acompanha
naquela hora da insônia vamos celebrar
se você tem uma taça de vinho para tomar
se você tem um amigo para conversar
vamos
é para te confortar tudo isso é
celebração à vida é generosa a vida é
generosa mesmo quando ela não parece
essa frase também está no meu livro cada
dia ela é mais viva em mim que a gente
possa em lutar no sentido de olhar e
nomear essa tristeza e ao mesmo tempo
que a gente possa celebrar que a gente
possa abraçar de uma forma muito
autêntica a celebração que é viver esse
dia e essa noite que luta e celebração
pelo que eu tenho estudado são como duas
faces da lua são como complementos como
luz e sombra então se eu não encontro
tempo de ir lutar e de me entristecer e
reconhecer que sim estou vivendo um
minuto talvez eu também não encontre
esse nome prazer essa nome alegria de
celebrar então esse é o meu convite para
você hoje permita que vem esse
sentimento não nomeado que já tomei
eu te dizer estabiliza que te deixa
exaustos cansando o nome dele é muto que
você o sinta o acolhia e em seguida que
venha a luz da celebração hoje completo
60 dias em lutando meus sentimentos e
agora com vocês a celebre essa
oportunidade maravilhosa de falarmos
sobre isso então obrigada e maravilhosa
família e